[Music]
okay so the whole prison and law
conversation often is framed around
drugs so we talked about this briefly
right before we started but we both have
some frustrations with our current
Attorney General so basically a few
years ago Obama's Assistant Attorney
General passed this memo or instigated
this memo that said that the feds
weren't going to go after states for
legalizing marijuana is that yes broadly
correct okay now it appears that
sessions is getting rid of that memo so
it's a little unclear does that mean
they're gonna start doing it or did he
just not like the memo or what as a
small government guy want the states to
be able to do whatever they want do you
have any insight into what's actually
going on here yeah and and and I'm not
certain that I disagree with the
Attorney General on the memo federal law
says this is illegal it's really strange
for DOJ to then come in with a memo that
says we're not going to enforce federal
law but what the memo does is just
leaves it to the discretion of local US
Attorney's and I would be surprised if
any of them decided that they wanted to
go after people for marijuana in states
where it's legalized but what really
needs to happen like the real solution
to this is not a memo from DOJ it's the
Congress saying we're not gonna be in
this business anymore let's let States
decide this you would think in a
Republican Congress that claims to be
for states rights that they would do
that I mean the West Coast has spoken
Alaska Washington Oregon California
Nevada Colorado I mean there there is a
movement here of states that have said
we as a policy matter think locking up
people for marijuana is not helping the
problem so what does this tell you about
the way the federal government works cuz
you're right a Republican administration
or Republican Congress everything else
by by logic if logic has anything to do
with politics which I know it often
doesn't they should not be going after
states I mean it's completely the
reverse of what they say they are for
now we don't know he's going to do it
that's what you're saying there may have
just been something in the memo that he
didn't like
but it just it just this is one of the
reasons that people just hate politics I
think yeah it's because it's so hard to
get movement on these issues and and
part of it is the politics of crime no
one runs on I'm gonna be smart about
criminal justice issues that's always we
got to be tough we got to be tough we
got to be tough but you know you look
and we have spent trillions of dollars
on the war on drugs we've locked up
hundreds of thousands of our citizens
and drug usage rates are pretty steady
over an entire 30-year period and it
turns out you just can't get around
addiction issues by locking people up
and the oppo opioid crisis is a good
example of that hosing mandatory minimum
sentences on people who are in the
throes of addiction is not going to work
because you could tell someone who's
addicted to heroin if you keep doing it
I'm gonna put you in prison for twenty
years and I'm not certain it would
matter yeah what they need is treatment
not present so what happens to that
conversation where our because you don't
hear I mean I guess you hear it a little
bit maybe but where are the politicians
or the public figures saying guys
instead of funding all of this money to
the prisons you know keeping these
people here forever all right
many of them going back right the day
after they get out all of this stuff
where are the people saying we have to
help them break addiction yeah I mean
the problem one of the problems I see is
we focused on back-end solutions and so
the Federal Bureau of Prisons is a third
of do J's budget if we stopped locking
up so many people and spent some of that
money on treatment or spent the money on
more federal law enforcement who
actually solved more crimes that might
actually deter people mm-hmm but just
punishing people through bit long
sentences is never gonna have that
deterrent effect that the government
wants and and you know you you also
can't say that we are the land of
liberty on the one hand and then on the
other recognize that we incarcerate our
citizens at a greater rate than almost
any other country on the planet yeah 2.2
million people in prisons are jail in
America today that's Houston yeah as you
say that that's more than some small
countries yeah
Houston locked up all around the country
and and for a country that claims to be
the land of the free those two things
are just incompatible and inconsistent
with each other yeah so I understand the
federal level and why there's so much
sort of gridlock with that are there any
states that are doing this really much
better than other states yeah Texas
recently closed a bunch of prisons and
decided that they were gonna try and
rehabilitate more people and as they
closed prisons and release more
prisoners you know what happened to
their crime rate it went down well turns
out there's not a great correlation
between crime rate and incarceration
rate people commit crimes for all sorts
of reasons the economy how the economy
is doing is probably the biggest factor
mm-hmm
but just locking people up is not going
to solve the problem of crime and you
know we have fairly historic low rates
of crime at the moment but you would
never know that by our Corrections
practices and by the number of people we
prosecute and put into prisons and jails
every day yeah what are some of your
other pet peeve issues I know the
mandatory minimum one I know is the big
president reform is another one it's
just my belief that if we are gonna let
someone out of prison someday why would
we not want to spend a little bit of
money for rehabilitation and job
training you spend a little bit of money
so that you save a whole lot of money by
not them getting out of prison and not
committing new crimes not being
reprosecution car serrated say spend a
little money to save a lot of money to
me that's good government is there
virtually no job training in federal
prison so you were sort of self-training
and I'm sure there are other people that
learn shop or learn some other traits
but is there really nothing well I mean
that they they have not allocated a
great deal of money towards that and
then the wardens of federal prisons have
a lot of discretion I'll give you one
example president I was at we had a
really great welding program men we're
learning this trade they were getting
out they were getting jobs paying twenty
five dollars an hour which that's the
gold standards great people getting out
people don't care if you
a felony if you can weld and do the job
25 bucks an hour if you get out of
college that EDC and and what a warden
Caymans thought well I can get more
money if I change the program so he
changed the welding program and put in
an associate's degree program in
business management because we know that
every person wants to hire a former
person from the prison to help manage
and run their business these are the
decisions I saw all the time in the
system and and most of them just don't
make any sense what we need to do is
open those prisons up get more
volunteers get businesses into the
prisons provide job training and basic
life skills somebody the men I served
time with had never had a bank account
and it's the little things when I got
out of prison I got to the halfway house
I was told you need to get a job before
we'll give you a pass to leave and you
can't get a job until you get a bank
account and I went to the bank and they
said you haven't banked for 11 years
what's the deal I had to tell them why
and then I find out that the credit
agencies had listed me as deceased
Jesus and so I go back to the halfway
house and I'm like I can't even get the
process started of getting a job because
I can't get a bank account and I said
well you need to hire a lawyer to get
this for ya I just did a lower GI Joe
yeah I need a lawyer that I can't afford
to get the bank account to get the job
to get the money yeah that doesn't
compute and for a lot of people when
they hit those roadblocks they don't
know how to cope with them and what they
do is they revert back to the things
they do now yeah I mean I mentioned
Shawshank before but it's like it
reminds me of both you know there was
red and the old guy with the bird I'm
blanking who is that blanking on his
name yeah but you know Reds Pat sees a
gun in the in the window and he's
thinking maybe I should get back in
there and the old guy like ends up
killing himself because they can't
function they just can't finalized
institutional when you are taken from a
system where everything is controlled
and you're in a system that says you are
a piece of garbage everyone in there
that is the message you get every day in
prison
that you are a piece of garbage where
you're here to suffer punishment and
you're not gonna get out and lead a
successful life that has an impact on
people you know I got out and wasn't
aware of what I could do I had but I had
a woman who was intelligent and
beautiful and who loved me who said you
can go to law school and I had a former
Solicitor General of the United States
telling me I could go to law school that
had a profound impact on me and my own
self-worth and whether I thought I could
do some of these things had I not had
that I don't think I would have even
tried to go to law school yeah so on
that note let's let's talk about some of
the good stuff so you're teaching law
now what are kids excited by it right
now like what do you see them caring
about criminal justice reform is a big
topic it's big everywhere I go I see
more people writing about it people
talking about it
Pew just put out a study yesterday
saying an overwhelming number of
Americans support criminal justice
reform and I think people get it like we
are sending people to prison too many
people to prison for too long we use
incarceration as a first response rather
than a last resort and it doesn't work
the irony is the longer you send someone
to prison the less likely they are to
come out and be law-abiding successful
citizens and so why are we doing it yeah
tell me a bit a little bit about about
teaching in general I mean it must be
pretty freakin rewarding for you to be
doing it is and it's fun when I'm
teaching fourth amendment to students or
fifth amendment Miranda issues yeah and
now I'm teaching a Prison Law and Policy
class where we are diving into both
legal doctrine about what are the
constitutional rights that prisoners
retain why they're incarcerated and
getting into the policy aspects of why
do we impose solitary confinement on
people we know that it makes people who
have mental illness it exacerbates their
mental illness and we know that people
without mental illness it causes it
mm-hmm so why would you want to impose
long terms of solitary confinement on
people that are eventually going to be
released from prison why are we putting
sex offenders in
present and not trying to rehabilitate
them before we kick them to the outside
world and before the neighbors for me
and my young kids anyone that has an out
date we should be trying to reform and
rehabilitate and I think with a little
bit of resources and opening presents up
to more volunteers we can make a big
impact on the recidivism rate so you
would basically want it sounds like you
basically want sort of less laws in
general perhaps even less funding or at
least you'd want to shift the funding to
some other things and then you think you
think volunteers and things like that
could actually help like I do I think
people would come in and teach courses
I've seen it in prisons I went to a
private prison in Texas in December and
this prison had allowed a company to
come in and build an assembly line and
this woman I spoke to at this woman's
prison said I'm making $9 an hour in
prison now she said the state takes $3
of that an hour but I make enough money
where I can send six or seven hundred
dollars to my daughter who is a Baylor
University for her rent she said I can't
tell you how great it feels to
contribute to my daughter's life and be
able to do it from here and she said I'm
gonna be able to take these skills that
I'm learning and go get a job with this
company or a similar company when I get
out of prison why would we not want to
do more of that yeah I think it's kind
of amazing that twice now you've used
Texas as an example of a state that's
doing this right I think if you would
have asked me before we sat down what
state probably has the most backwards
legal laws and Prison laws I probably
would have said Texas which is probably
just a terrible stereotype but that's
really interesting
well Texas has its issues too I mean
there's no state that's doing it well
but there are states that are ramping
down punishments and realizing that if
we do put people in prison we need to
incentivize them people that are in
prison respond to incentives just like
anyone else
California recently passed a bill that
incentivizes prisoners by cutting their
sentence short if they take
rehabilitation programing and that's
something that we my company president
professors are talking with correctional
associations all over the country about
this is what you should be doing
incentive eyes excellence when I was in
prison all of the things I did the legal
briefs I won two Supreme Court cases
court cases all over the country it was
clear to people in the prison that I was
on a different trajectory than a lot of
people and that I was not going to be a
safety risk when I got out and yet no
matter what I did it didn't sortin my
sentence by one day and I tell you that
you know the first five years in prison
I deserve to be there but I grew up and
I found the law and got responsibility
and the last five years I wasn't a
danger to anyone else I had grown up and
I was just warehoused yeah so I know you
focus obviously mostly on criminal law
it's the most personal thing to you and
it's what you're teaching and everything
else what are the other parts of the law
laws that we're not paying a tendon of
attention to for example you just
mentioned the Fourth Amendment right to
privacy I feel like people don't even
understand that we have a right to
privacy yeah yeah I mean the Fourth
Amendment is a really tough area of law
because there aren't any hard and fast
rules and because of the exclusionary
rule courts are very reticent to say
there's a Fourth Amendment violation
because the consequence is all of the
evidence is thrown out and the person
may go yeah maybe the cases gets
dismissed right there's an interesting
catch-22 yeah and so you know what you
see is is courts I mean the Supreme
Court slowly starting to get more
concerned about technology and privacy
there's a big case pending up there
about whether your cellphone metadata
requires a warrant for the government to
go get a warrant before they can look at
that data and you know with GPS
technology these days they can get your
data from your cell phone and tell
exactly what you've been doing where
you've gone if you visit a doctor
they'll know you may have an illness if
they see you've done it several times so
in effect has the ship sailed on that
then I mean how do we have a right to
privacy we don't in the digital age yeah
it's really difficult this is one of the
reasons why it's so hard for people
coming out of prison because there are
so many collateral consequences be
discriminated against in housing and
employment you can lose your voting
rights
and you can't really hide it anymore so
we have all these initiatives to ban the
Box banned the question on the
application mmm-hmm
but if employers can just run a google
search and find out that you committed a
felony I'm not certain that just pushing
that information to the interview is
going to lead to more people getting
jobs right and so I would like to see
more groups just go to employers go to
big companies and say affirmatively hire
people coming out of prison try it maybe
give them a tax break or some sort of
incentive to get them to employ these
people because there are a whole lot of
people coming out we want the primary
reason why they go back to committing
crimes is they can't find employment and
a place to live yeah you mentioned to me
briefly in the green room that you're
trying to work on some stuff with the
White House right now yeah so I sat at
the table a couple weeks ago as the
president said that we need prison
reform and they're trying to push a bill
in the house I start in the house that
would provide incentives to prisoners to
take rehabilitation programs so that we
can reduce the recidivism rate and I'm a
big believer that that we can if we
structure things in the appropriate
manner yeah so on this case this sounds
like something good that Trump's trying
to push through which usually isn't
prison reform usually thought of as a
lefty or a progressive idea it is but
there are more and more conservative
groups who understand that the criminal
justice system has gotten too big and
compasses too much law too many things
are criminalized and we are over relying
on incarceration and it's funny I go
around to every single group in DC the
Heritage Foundation Cato the Koch
Institute ACLU and double-a-c-p these
people can agree on nothing but they all
agree that the criminal justice system
as a massaman to be fixed yeah what do
you see is there giant differences
though in the solution so I would
imagine some of the ones on the right
you just mentioned they just want the
government to do less or get rid of some
regulation as ones on the left want the
government probably to do more yeah I
mean I think everyone realizes we need
to reevaluate sentences and the lengths
of sentences I think there's
disagreement with various how various
crimes are prosecuted like environmental
crimes Congress likes to pass statutes
without what they call mens rea uh
requirements that you knowingly violated
the law and people on the Left would say
it's really hard to get CEOs and
companies that do this to be prosecuted
if you have the mens rea oh whereas on
the right they're a big believer that
mens rea a' is a necessary part if we're
gonna send you to prison you shouldn't
it's because you knowingly violated the
law mm-hmm yeah that's or knowingly
committed an act of violated the law
right but as you were saying before
there are so many laws at this point
that really nobody knows nobody knows
yeah you have 5,000 statutes over 5,000
no one has an accurate count the Cary
criminal penalties now administrative
agencies can sometimes create
regulations with criminal penalties and
you have a California you probably have
another two or three thousand statutes
so there are eight nine ten thousand
things that you can do wrong that may
lead to you going to jail or prison I
would say that state legislatures and
the Congress does not value individual
liberty if that's the case we went for
the majority of this country's founding
we went and used civil penalties fines
money damages to solve a lot of these
problems and somewhere along the way in
the 70s and 80s we thought we needed to
fix everything with prison sentences
yeah I mean it's just it's it's so
backwards you know it mean like I think
a lot of my audience watching this is
going
I like intuitively you just know this
that there's something so just wrong
with this system and yet it just keeps
trucking along so maybe look if trump's
passing something that that you're
involved in and it gets to the house
maybe something a little moving
yeah I'm greatly encouraged by the White
House's passion for this issue Jared
Kushner is incredibly passionate about
it his dad went to federal prison in
2002 he's been directly impacted most
people I know don't understand the
criminal justice system till a family
member
caught up and then they realize oh my
gosh this is a mess yeah and a huge
problem and you know I think I think
conservatives in the house and in the
Senate will get on board with prison
reform and my hope is that it will be a
piece of bipartisan legislation because
this is one of the few bipartisan issues
that we have in the country yeah I'm
curious do you ever coach any any
inmates now you ever go to a prison and
find somebody and be like you know let
me tell you my story I have a lot of
people I stay in contact with presence I
go into prisons and give talks all the
time my recent thing has been mentoring
people that have committed serious
felonies who are now on their way to
currently in or recently graduated from
law school and a lot of them are now
getting law licenses this summer well
and it's been interesting to see because
I probably had several hundred lawyers
tell me you can never go to law school
even if you do graduate from law school
no State Bar Association is ever gonna
let you become an attorney and they were
just wrong yeah and so I got to argue a
case for one of my friends in the
Washington State Supreme Court this past
fall it was the first time the court had
taken what they call a character and
fitness case whether you have the
character and fitness necessary to
practice law first time they had taken a
case in 37 years argued the case on the
way home on the plane I get a text
saying that the court ruled unanimously
two hours after the oral argument in
favor of my client
well she's now gonna take the bar exam
in February and she'll probably be a
lawyer by May so the counter-argument
was simply that she had been in jail
basically so she been in jail she had
had drug addiction issues although she'd
been clean for six years
and she had had extraordinary success in
law school graduated with honors had won
all of these awards had been appointed
to commissions by the governor of
Washington and supported by a huge
amount of licensed attorneys and the bar
still tonight or six today so then we
have to waste all this time and money
and energy and resources to allow her to
go
yeah what do we do to get rid of all of
that so cuz a lot of what you're talking
about is just generally I think what
people are frustrated by with government
just like this mid-level bloat nobody
really knows what's going on there are
either a zillion laws or resilient
regulations that half of them conflict
with each other just all of that what do
you really do to remove I don't know
like the occupational licensing schemes
are really impactful for people coming
out of prison because many of them say
if you have a felony we're just not
letting you do these professions right
and you know so they don't want to clean
the pool or something you lazy I don't I
don't think that we need people coming
out who have committed sex offenses
teaching and junior high schools I get
that sometimes there are offenses that
apply to a particular job but most of
these things aren't looking at the crime
the person committed it's just across
the board policy of you're not going to
be allowed in the profession and when
you lock people coming out of prison
from all of these professions you make
it very difficult for them to ever get
back to having a real life yeah well
your story is obviously inspiring so
this is I've really enjoyed this did we
did we miss anything major on the legal
front that would you'd absolutely knock
out like I feel like we hit your you
know yeah good you know we did our whole
Star Wars talk already on the green
whoops I think we're good
well it's a pleasure chatting with you
and for more on Sean you can follow him
on Twitter it's Sean Hopwood that's sth
o n h o P wo OD
you
[Music]